لذلك نقدم USBC إلى iPhone 15. الآن
يمكن للكابل نفسه شحن Mac iPad
iPhone وحتى الجيل الثاني من airpods Pro
والذي تم تحديثه بموصل USBC [
موسيقى]
إذا كانت سماعات الهواء الخاصة بك منخفضة الطاقة،
فيمكنك شحنها أو حتى شحنها  Apple Watch
مباشرة من جهاز iPhone Dynamic Island الخاص بك، وهي
كاميرا رئيسية بدقة 48 ميجابكسل توفر تقريب
2X وa16 الكتروني، وهي تتمتع
بقدرات لا يتمتع بها أي هاتف ذكي آخر
مثل القدرة على الحصول على المساعدة في حالات الطوارئ
والمساعدة على الطريق عندما تكون خارج
الشبكة هذا العام.  نقدم لك
الجيل التالي من الصور الشخصية على iPhone،
التقط هذه الصورة فائقة الدقة.
يمكنك الآن تبديل التركيز من
موضوع إلى آخر بعد
التقاط الصورة، وسيتم توجيهك إليهم مباشرة
مع توجيهات ومسافة واضحة
مدمجة في العثور على ذلك  إنه يتمتع
بنفس إجراءات حماية الخصوصية التي أصبح المستخدمون
يثقون بها
[الموسيقى]
نعتقد أنك ستستخدم هذا طوال الوقت مع
تقديم النقر المزدوج، ما
عليك سوى النقر بإصبعي السبابة والإبهام معًا مرتين، ومن السهل جدًا استخدام النقر المزدوج للرد على مكالمة
اسمحوا لي أن أعرض لكم
[موسيقى]
مرحبًا ديدرا، مرحبًا جيف
أجنبي